enfin état et collectivités doivent
s'organiser pour que les entreprises
disposent interlocuteurs bien identifiés
dans une logique de guichet unique
je veillerai bien sûr à l'avenir à ce
que les collectivités il participe qui
participent soit dûment associés aux
procédures et informer des aides
accordées sur leur territoire c'est ce
n'est que dans une logique partenariale
ce n'est que dans une logique
partenariale très forte qu état et
collectivités trouverons les solutions
les plus adaptées pour préparer l'avenir
de nos territoires
le gouvernement veut répondre à la crise
qui nous touche et c'est par elle que se
prépare à l'après